ahora que ya hemos visto el mecanismo
para una reacción s n 1 echemos un
vistazo a la estéreo química empecemos
con una luro de alquilo este carbono
tiene una hibridación sp3 en el primer
paso del mecanismo estos electrones se
irán con nuestro grupo saliente el
halógeno entonces dibujemos el halógeno
por acá tiene otro par de electrones lo
que le da una carga formal negativa -1 y
le hemos quitado un enlace al átomo de
carbono ahora se ha quedado con tres
enlaces y ha cambiado su hibridación de
s&p 3 como lo teníamos del lado
izquierdo
ahora tiene una hibridación sp2
recuerden la hibridación sp2 da una
geometría tribunal- plana lo que
significa que todos estos enlaces están
en el mismo plano
un carbono espetos tiene un orbital p
que no está every visado aquí está el
orbital p y el carbono tiene una carga
formal positiva es un electro filo
quiere electrones entonces el siguiente
paso del mecanismo es la entrada del
núcleo filo aquí está nuestro núcleo
filo con su par de electrones tiene una
carga formal negativa y es atraída por
la carga positiva del electro filo
nuestro carbó catión el núcleo filo
tiene dos posibles lugares para poder
atacar este par de electrones puede
atacar por arriba o por abajo del
carbono eso ya lo hemos visto antes
obtendremos una mezcla de productos 50%
del ataque por arriba y 50% del ataque
por abajo o al menos eso esperaríamos
sin embargo nuestro grupo saliente el
halógeno que está cargado negro
la mente protege al carbono del ataque
el núcleo físico la carga positiva y
negativa se atraen y formarán lo que
llamamos un pánico así que el núcleo
filo no querrá atacar por abajo si puede
pero la mayor parte del tiempo preferir
a atacar por arriba así que obtendremos
una mezcla de productos que no será
exactamente del 50 y 50 por ciento
dibujemos los productos del ataque el
núcleo físico a nuestro electro filo
si el núcleo filo ataca por arriba forma
un enlace con el carbono y eso cambia
nuevamente la hibridación del carbono
sp2 a sp3 y si el núcleo filo ataca por
abajo empujará los enlaces y también
cambiará la hibridación a sp3 es por eso
que nos importa la stereo química pues
terminamos con un carbono de hibridación
sp3 ahora comparemos nuestros productos
con la molécula de haluro de alquilo que
teníamos inicialmente en el producto de
la derecha el núcleo filo quedó en el
mismo lugar donde estaba originalmente
el halógeno eso significa que hay
retención de la configuración absoluta
es decir no importa qué es lo que esté
unido a este carbono la configuración no
cambia si la configuración es r
es r o si es ese se quedará como ese
ahora en el producto de la izquierda
podemos ver que el núcleo filo ha
quedado arriba eso provoca la inversión
de la configuración en nuestro centro
quiral por lo que obtendremos un poco
más del 50% de este producto el producto
con la inversión de la configuración
inversión y obtendremos un poco menos
del 50 por ciento de este producto el
producto con retención de la
configuración absoluta retención en este
producto hay inversión y en este hay
retención veamos un ejemplo de la
estéreo química para las reacciones del
tipo s n 1 vamos a ver dibujaré un
alumno del kilo
este es un ciclo hexano y pondré dos
grupos metilo por aquí un bromo por acá
y usando la estéreo química nos queda un
grupo metilo lejos de nosotros ahí está
este es nuestro alumno de alquilo y lo
haremos reaccionar con n a más s h - el
primer paso es identificar a nuestro
grupo saliente el halógeno bromo ese es
nuestro grupo saliente ahora cuál es el
núcleo filo bueno aquí tenemos a la
unión hidro sulfuro está cargado
negativamente ese h - es nuestro núcleo
filo y el bromo es el grupo saliente
pensemos en el mecanismo estos
electrones estos del enlace se irán con
el bromo y nos queda un kart vocaciòn lo
dibujaré
aquí están los grupos metilo y por aquí
hay otro grupo metilo
este es nuestro carbó catión está
cargado positivamente observen lo que le
pasó a este carbono originalmente tenía
una hibridación sp3 y ahora tiene una
hibridación sp2 por eso he dibujado una
línea recta indicando que es una
hibridación sp2 ya puede ocurrir el
ataque núcleo físico el a nyon s h -
atacara al carbó catión puede atacar por
cualquier lado del anillo así que
obtendremos dos productos cuáles son los
productos que resultarán de este ataque
bueno primero dibujaré un anillo
digamos que el núcleo filo ataca por
arriba aquí nos queda el sh y empujó al
grupo metilo lejos de nosotros
otro posible producto se obtiene si el
núcleo filo peligroso el foro en lugar
de atacar por arriba ataca por abajo
forma un enlace con el carbono y empuja
al grupo metilo hacia arriba así nos
quedan los productos si observamos la
molécula que teníamos al inicio podemos
ver que originalmente el bromo estaba
hacia nosotros y aquí nos quedó el sh
hacia nosotros
esta es la retención de la configuración
absoluta mientras que en el segundo
producto el sh ha quedado lejos de
nosotros este es el producto con
inversión de la configuración recuerden
que hay preferencia por la formación del
producto invertido pues el bromo nuestro
grupo saliente
forma un parque único con el carb
ocasión impidiendo el ataque entonces
siempre tomen en cuenta la estéreo
química con los productos que obtengan
en una reacción sn uno busca en los
centros finales y si tienen alguno
piensen en los productos que implican
estéreo química